JOE BIDEN WITH A WEAKENED AND
GROUNDBREAKING SOCIAL DISTANCING
TECHNIQUES.
RAYMOND ARROYO HAS IT ALL IN
"SEEN AND UNSEEN," BUT FIRST,
WHAT IS REALLY ESSENTIAL?
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
AFTER ALMOST TWO MONTHS NOW OF
LOCKDOWN FROM AMERICA IS FINALLY
REOPENING.
GOLF, NASCAR.
THEY WERE ON TELEVISION THIS
WEEKEND AND MOST STATES ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF DISMANTLING THEIR
RESTRICTIONS.
>> GETTING TO THE BEACH AND FOR
A LOT OF FAMILIES, GETTING BACK
TO NORMAL WHICH IS GREAT.
>> IT IS A SIGN OF HOPE AND
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
>> WE ARE APPRECIATIVE THAT THE
JUDGE, ONCE AGAIN REINSTATED THE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS WITH A
BIBLICAL COMMAND TO DO IT.
>> DON’T FEEL COMFORTABLE, DON’T
GO OUT, BUT I WILL SAY THIS, I
THINK IT IS GREAT TO SEE THINGS
OPENING BACK UP.
IT IS GOING TO BE WONDERFUL FOR
THE COUNTRY.
THE ONE IF YOU DON’T FEEL
COMFORTABLE STAY HOME.
THAT’S WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SAYING BUT THIS IS AN EXERCISE
IN BASIC FREEDOM AND IT WAS MET
WITH BABYLONIAN RESPONSE OF
OUTRAGE FROM THE USUAL LOCKDOWN
LACKEY.
>> THEY WERE STILL A GREAT DEAL
OF TREPIDATION AND UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT WHERE ALL OF THIS IS
HEADED.
WE ARE IN A PRECARIOUS SITUATION
RIGHT NOW.
>> EXPERTS WARN TOO MUCH TOO
SOON.
>> WHAT I THINK YOU SHOULD TAKE
FROM IT IS THAT WE ARE, IN FACT
FLAMING THE FIRE HERE.
>> SECOND WAVES ARE PERSISTENT
AND REAL.
>> Laura: OF COURSE BLUE STATE
SUCH AS WASHINGTON, MICHIGAN,
CALIFORNIA, AND ILLINOIS ARE
SLOW WALKING THERE REOPENING.
BUT IT IS HARD TO SEE AND WATCH
WHAT IS HAPPENING AROUND YOU.
IT IS HARD TO SEE IT LASTING
MUCH LONGER.
WHILE THE VIRUS TOOK A
DEVASTATING TOLL ON THE COUNTRY,
HOSPITALIZATIONS COAST TO COAST
HAVE EITHER DECLINED OR LEVELED
OFF.
THAT IS GOOD NEWS.
AND ALSO PROMISING VACCINE NEWS
ALSO CAME OUT TODAY FROM
MODERNA.
WALL STREET REACTED WELL WITH
THE DOW JONES JUMPING FOUR
PERCENTAGE POINTS.
MORE GOOD NEWS.
OF COURSE WE HOPE AND PRAY THE
REOPENING DOES GO WELL.
BUT NOW THAT WE HAVE MOVED PAST
THE IMMEDIATE HOSPITAL CRISIS,
IT IS TIME WE THINK HARD ABOUT
WHAT THE STATE LEADERS HAVE DONE
IN THE NAME OF SAFETY.
NOW FROM THE OUTSET WITHOUT THE
INVOLVEMENT OF STATE
LEGISLATURES, GOVERNORS TOLD US
WHAT WAS AND WHAT WAS NOT
ESSENTIAL.
CERTAINLY THE CENTRAL BUSINESSES
COULD REMAIN OPEN.
LIQUOR STORES, POT DISPENSARIES
COME ABORTION FACILITIES, PET
AND GARDEN STORES BECOME STORES
COMEDY CENTRAL.
CHURCHES, JAMS, SCHOOLS,
BASKETBALL, TENNIS COURTS,
PLAYGROUNDS, NONESSENTIAL.
SO WHAT CRITERIA WERE USED?
FOR MANY PEOPLE OF FAITH,
COMMUNAL SURFACE IS ESSENTIAL
AND ARGUABLY FOR THEM THE MOST
ESSENTIAL THING IN THEIR LIVES.
AND WHILE I’M REALLY GLAD I
COULD BUY MOUNTAIN BIKE FOR MY
SON A FEW WEEKS AGO, WHY ARE
THOSE SHOPS OPEN THE OUTDOOR
EXERCISE CLASSES NOT ALLOWED?
SO WE SEE THIS AS A ALL
SUBJECTIVE, SELF SUBJECTIVE IN
THE END AND DRIVEN USUALLY BY
UNACCOUNTABLE TECHNOCRATS, BUT
IT HAS PROFOUND CONSEQUENCES FOR
OUR LIVES.
ONLY NOW, WE KNOW HOW SCREWED UP
IMPERIAL COLLEGE PROJECTIONS
WERE.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT I BELIEVE
EARLY APRIL BUT NOW EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS IT.
NO WONDER THE CHIEF MODELER NEIL
FERGUSON WOULDN’T SHARE HIS
COMPUTER CODE WITHIN THE ONE
THAT HE USED TO DRIVE THOSE
PROJECTIONS.
NOW THAT WE SERVE THE CARNAGE,
HUMAN AND ECONOMIC, WE SHOULD
TAKE STOCK OF WHAT REALLY IS
ESSENTIAL.
NUMBER ONE, BETTER EXPERTS.
IT IS TIME TO CLEAR OUT THE
COBWEBS.
WHY ARE PEOPLE WHO SCREWED UP SO
BADLY IN THE PAST STILL IN THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR AND
THEY KEEP GETTING IT WRONG, AND
STAYING IN THEIR JOBS, WHY?
NUMBER TWO CIVIL LIBERTIES FROM
OBVIOUSLY ESSENTIAL FREEDOM TO
ASSOCIATE.
FREEDOM TO WORSHIP, FREEDOM OF
SPEECH, FREEDOM TO DISAGREE WITH
THE PREVAILING WINDS.
THESE RIGHTS ARE INNATELY A
BOWL.
THEY CAN ONLY BE A BRIDGE FOR A
NARROWLY TAILORED PURPOSE, NOT
INDEFINITELY.
>> I’M HERE BECAUSE WE ALL
DESERVE FREEDOM.
WE’VE DONE EVERYTHING WE’VE BEEN
ASKED TO DO AND ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH.
I THINK AMERICANS NEED TO
REALIZE THE FREEDOMS ARE BEING
TAKEN AWAY, AND IF THEY DON’T
STAND UP FOR THEM RIGHT NOW,
THERE WON’T BE ANY FREEDOM TO
STAND UP FOR IT.
>> Laura: THESE RIGHTS ARE
ARGUABLY MORE DURING THE CRISIS
RIGHT NOW DURING THE GOOD TIMES.
I REMEMBER WHEN LIBERALS USED TO
BELIEVE THIS.
NOW THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION, WELL, IT SEEMS ONLY TO
DEFEND ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND
ABORTION RIGHTS OR PERSONS
PERHAPS, BUT THESE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN DEPRIVED OF THESE
LAST FEW MONTHS WE DON’T HEAR
FROM THE ACLU.
NUMBER THREE, TEACHING THE
CONSTITUTION IS ESSENTIAL.
HOW MANY TODAY REALLY KNOW WHAT
IT SAYS, WHAT IT MEANS?
WHY IT EVEN MATTERS AND WHY DOES
DECLARATION MATTER?
THESE DOCUMENTS ULTIMATELY
PROTECT US FROM A GOVERNMENT
DRUNK ON ITS OWN POWER.
ONE THAT ENDS UP SUBJUGATING ITS
OWN PEOPLE FOR THEIR OWN BOTTOM
LINE OR THEIR OWN STATUS OR
THEIR OWN GOOD.
NUMBER FOUR, A PROSPEROUS
ECONOMY IS ESSENTIAL.
THAT MEANS NOT JUST FOR THE
ELITES AT THE TOP, BUT FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND ENTRY-LEVEL
WORKERS AS WELL.
>> WE ARE NOT GETTING PAID.
>> TO PAY MY BILLS.
>> MY WIFE IS A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER AS WELL.
WE ACTUALLY HAD TO CLOSE THE
DOORS THERE SO THAT CRIPPLED US.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS ANSWER A
SOCIALISM PEER THAT WILL ONLY
BRING MISERY.
WE HAVE SEEN OUT ACROSS THE
GLOBE OVER THE DECADES IN THE
LAST CENTURY WE HAVE SEEN IT.
A GROWING ECONOMY MEANS A
HEALTHY AMERICA ACROSS THE
BOARD.
NUMBER 5, ENDING SOCIAL MEDIA
CENSORSHIP IS ESSENTIAL.
IF SOMETHING OR SOMEONE DOESN’T
COMPORT WITH THE W.H.O.
GUIDELINES ON COVID-19, GUESS
WHAT?
IF YOU PUT THAT IN A VIDEO, YOUR
POST THAT MAY BE EVIDENCE, IT
WILL BE PULLED DOWN.
>> ANYTHING THAT WOULD GO
AGAINST WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION OR A VIOLATION SO
REMOVE IS ANOTHER IMPORTANT PART
OF OUR POLICY.
>> Laura: UNBELIEVABLE.
IN A MOMENT YOU WILL HEAR FROM
MY NEXT GUEST A VICTIM OF SUCH
CENSORSHIP A RENOWNED
EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND
BIOSTATISTICIAN.
NUMBER SIX, SCIENCE THAT ISN’T
INFECTED BY MONEY OR POLITICS IS
ESSENTIAL.
FROM CLIMATE CHANGE TO COVID-19,
WE HAVE SEEN FAR TOO MANY
MEMBERS OF THE PERMANENT MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT.
MAY BE COMPROMISED OR AT LEAST
THE APPEARANCE OF BEING
COMPROMISED BY TIES TO BIG
PHARMA OR MAYBE EVEN THEIR OWN
POLITICAL PROCLIVITIES.
THAT HAS TO END.
THAT HAS TO END IN ORDER FOR
MORE AMERICANS TO TRUST NEW
VACCINES, OTHER TREATMENTS OR
EVEN THEIR POINT OF VIEW ON
ISSUES.
AND NUMBER SEVEN, YOU COME AT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU ARE
ESSENTIAL.
YOUR VOICES, YOUR HARD WORK,
YOUR DEVOTION TO FAMILY, TO YOUR
FAITH TO PLAY BY THE RULES.
THIS IS YOUR GOVERNMENT.
THEY WORK FOR YOU.
NEVER LET THEM FORGET THAT.
I HAVE ALWAYS HAD MORE GOOD
SENSE TO MOST OF THE SO-CALLED
EXPERTS OUT THERE WHO WANT TO
ORDER YOU AROUND AND ENJOY IT.
KEEP PUNCHING BACK.
KEEP QUESTIONING.
DON’T BE AFRAID.
YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO WANTS
YOU TO BE HEALTHY.
WHO WANT YOU TO BE PROSPEROUS,
BUT MOST OF ALL, WHO WANT YOU TO